hey guys tony and peter here we just got
to play the nintendo switch and one of
the games we played is shown off in the
stream event the night before little
game called arms arms okay well yes it
is about arms but this is like a
fighting game or a boxing game in a
sense yeah and it uses the motion you
know joy cons and you are throwing one
fist or another that you know the
conceit here is that you are controlling
these characters with long expendable
arms so they're like Springs and so
you're sort of fighting across the other
side of an arena from someone pretty far
away and that actually leads to some
pretty interesting timing elements I
found the game to be more intuitive than
I thought it was going to be but how did
you feel I noticed that you were
expressing some frustration during the
demo yeah um so you you hold the two joy
cons and then to move your you're almost
doing like like an RC control right
where it's almost like these are the
joysticks and you're moving around and
you so you can jump and dash and use
that use the shoulders to do that but I
found myself and maybe it's because of
the predecessor being the wii i found
myself wanting to just flick up brian
jump but of course that's not how it's
done so upon wanting to jump I would
often throw a punch instead there was
also a block motion which i think it was
like like this or like occur the
controllers yeah I just never it never
wanted to do that for me and again I
would intend a block and instead threw a
punch and then I'm wide open for you to
just clobber me right back you know yeah
the game requires a lot of coordination
probably more so than any of Nintendo's
like motion controlled games before
after a few minutes I felt pretty
comfortable like yes blocking did not
feel totally natural but I could see
with a few more hours in this game maybe
that would come the question is does
this game have longevity right I think
when you compare it to we boxing which
is sort of an easy comparison to make
because it feels like a big evolution of
that yeah it's you've got this cast of
characters this time so it's not just to
me is kind of pummeling each other so
you know you may find a particular
character that you like you may sort of
go through the roster I don't know there
may be some sort of tournament mode or
in arcade mode to it we don't really
know but with that on top of it I would
say it would have at least some
longevity right I mean I could
definitely see people really getting
into this but it might be a small
audience
his game is pretty unusual it's
certainly not as accessible as something
like wii sports in the boxing it plays
in a quirky manner it looks in a quirky
way so it's the splatoon to boxing games
basically I'd say that's an epic effects
yeah alright well thank you very much
Peter guys for more nintendo switched
game play previews interviews all that
good stuff keep a lock the game spot
[Music]